my name is Kenneth Claire I've been
incarcerated since 1985 almost 32 years
for a crime I did not commit did you
kill them no I did not know I did not I
did not kill them too righteous have no
idea who did but it wasn't me
we have a witness who says I saw a white
man commits a murder the white man had a
mustache she wore a white shirt black
belt white pants later on about four or
five days later he then changed to
characterize the perpetrator of the
crime as a black man
immediacy is far more accurate than
leader reports the more time that passes
between their initial report and
subsequent report the more opportunity
for this influence to take place on the
one hand he had his perception his
vision telling him that this was a white
male and he knew the difference between
white and black and he had adults in his
life important people his mother his
mother boyfriend who believed that it
was a black male now how to reconcile
that I believe that he incorporated the
information from the adult witnesses but
just add it on a black male on to the
crime so that story then incorporates
the demands of the adults the black male
and his perceptions I saw a white man at
a psychological level I believe very
strongly that this information would be
essential for the Trier of fact the jury
to have that a witness initially said
that the person who did this crime was
not a black male
I was a juror on the Kenneth clear trial
if I had known maybe some of the
evidence that wasn't presented to us I
probably would have voted differently if
I I'd known that the child actually said
that the person was white this child had
actually seen the crime being committed
I think that would have affected my
decision yes
his girlfriend or whoever she was she
was wired and he made comments like well
no one saw me go in no one saw me go out
and there were things that he said that
made him sound guilty to me I have the
recording here and I wanted to play it
and have you react tell me what's going
on in the recording you say they can't
prove a [ __ ] thing not unless
you open your [ __ ] mouth all
right what is that ok that man see what
you don't hear in there yes dad her
telling me that they are pressuring her
you know I mean I have been involved
with with the criminal justice system so
I you know I know that if you don't open
your mouth if you don't talk to them
because she telling me that they want to
talk to her and if you don't talk to him
then you know it's nothing they can do
to you if you don't open up your [ __ ]
my office nothing they can do to you I
wasn't speaking in the sense that I had
anything to tell her about that because
I had already denied
hey tell me know what it means no no I
didn't do you remember hearing the part
of the recording where Claire kind of
clear denies committing the murder you
know I'm not going to say yes sir yes
because I really don't remember one of
the most important elements or advice I
can give anyone in this situation that I
am in is if you're able to try to hire
an independent investigator someone that
works for you you know they can bring
about a change see they did something
that no one had done and that would be
to fully investigate the case and pull
the evidence pops up he uncovered the
fact that they was secretly running
testing and have been running tests
none of the other attorneys none of the
other investigators listened to what i
was saying i was constantly saying in my
case has never been fully investigated
why do you think it is that all these
professional attorneys couldn't get that
done but one guy who runs a small
private I business got something done
they don't I was guilty they thought I
was guilty and didn't see any need to
invest their resources I'm stead of
trying to get a new trial that's all I'm
asking for it's a new trial if you
convict me don't want even hear from
clarity you know I just going on and
just you know find me a spot in some
prison and you live my life jurors make
the best decisions judgments on their
own if they have all the information if
he's an innocent man and I actually
contributed to him being put on death
row that's something I have to live with
the rest of my life and I feel bad about
that but I hope if he didn't do it he
gets another trial I hope that all works
out for him oh that's all I have home
holy faith that's what I had that's what
I stand
Oh
you